poor Gabor Gabor Gabor bhaga bhaga bhaga
bhaga I'm back
[Music]
good evening I'm Papa Gloria what did he
do just tell me
what oopsie did Peter Pied you to drag
me out of my retirement I thought I was
done I thought he'd just move on playing
Minecraft unbelievable what'd he do he
tried to donate to a charity oh that's
bad
BBC posted pity pie cancels 50,000
donation to an t hate group I messed up
great Idol BBC very nice here's what
actually happened ah we're back at it
again aren't we and I'll explain their
full context really quickly for my
hundred million reward video I wanted to
donate to a charity to celebrate hitting
100 million subscribers and I thought a
charity that is against racism and
anti-semitism made sense to sort of put
an end to a lot of bad chapters in the
past that are way over spoken about and
it's it's just boring me at this point
but the internet it's started freaking
out because they were like why are you
donating to this charity this charity
celebrated you losing your precision
with Disney this charity has also done
other things are kind of questionable
and worth criticism and it's almost like
it was taking a way bigger stance than
just wanting to stop racism and
anti-semitism it became way more than
that for a lot of people and the more I
looked into the charity and I don't want
to go into the specific of why I don't
think the charity is as bad as everyone
says but at the same time it just didn't
make sense for me to donate it to it so
I said I'm gonna still donate just to
another charity with the same idea and
the same intent behind it just another
charity if you have a recommendation I
would love to hear it in the comments by
the way because I am still donating okay
but of course I mean I knew it was gonna
be taken badly but the headlines are
just amazing first BBC of
I really like the addition of the quote
I messed up kinda be like as if I was
saying oh I messed up for trying to
donate to this anti hate group how could
I try to stop hate oh what a mess up I
thanks BBC seriously and then Twitter
PewDiePie retracts fifty thousand dollar
donation to Jewish and the hate group
how could he I'm still get a donate now
the craziest part about this whole thing
hasn't even been addressed yet which was
the sweater I wore Twitter lost her mind
over the sweater I wore which was one of
those things that at first was kind of
funny and then he's just spiraled into
something like okay this is just messed
up like what's actually wrong with
people so some people took this sweater
as a way to for me to symbolize to Nazis
that I'm a Nazi this is how people think
I'm not even chained like it this is not
even a straw man this is what people
think that cross people were very sure
that that was Nazi cross and people
started yeah attacking me because of it
never mind the fact that it's Georgian
characters literally right next to it
never mind the fact that I've wore it
many times before of my channel and the
only time I've seen people comment about
it has been Georgian people with
excitement I don't think about what I
wear that much I don't even know about
the Iron Cross I think I heard something
about it but I don't think about these
things I don't care about these tiny
Nazi references like it's just crazy
Twitter even had to update the whole
thing about to clarify that the symbol
was actually not a Nazi cross what he
didn't wear a Nazi outfit and even then
a lot of people were saying like the
German Cross is not necessarily Nazi
thing in general but that was not even
what it was the crossing Georgia is a
very important symbol it's literally
used in their flag and the brand I was
wearing vent Mons is anything but a Nazi
brand and a lot of people would be like
oh he doesn't care about Georgia I've
been like I've spoken about this brand
before I really like this brand because
they do a lot of dumb stuff like having
a sweater that's inside out how quirky
but then also doing serious stuff like
the designer is
from Georgia he did this collection to
bring attention to what it was like
growing up in Georgia during that war
ridden period it was funny seeing people
retract their initial statement about
this as well like oh actually I find out
it's a Georgian cross and not an actual
Nazi cross but he's still an idiot for
wearing it I mean now we're talking at
least like that's a fair argument that I
can actually agree with if people think
it's irresponsible of me and maybe I
should know more sure
like that's criticism I can actually
take but too blatantly just say he did
this because he's a Nazi it's the
dumbest thing ever and all these people
retracting their statement about it it's
almost the same thing as me retracting
my donation because I didn't find out
all the information yet what crazy how
people do they accept I'm not calling
anyone horrible things it's ridiculous I
want to point out I think both ends of
the extreme are complete lunatics
delusional you know Nazis that think I'm
trying to signalize to them by wearing a
Georgian sweater you're idiots and the
opposite of people trying to pinpoint me
as a Nazi to make me some sort of
villain you're idiots too and me for
wearing something that could be
referenced although it was completely
nodding my mind at all makes me an idiot
too we're all idiots
congratulations you know it's the exact
same thing that happened a few months
ago when the same thing you know I was
trying to do something nice this time I
was trying to do anything and then the
other time I try to give a shout out to
a bunch of smaller channels I thought
that was a good idea and then what was
it like 30 channels I mean one of them
had like this super edgy joke hidden
into it like 40 minutes into the video
and I said I like this channel because
of anime reviews whatever and then
headlines PT PI gives shout-out to
hateful anti-semitic YouTube channel and
the whole crowd just goes see I knew it
was a Nazi this is evidence because
people just read the headlines or take
it the way they want to but you under
when you understand the full context of
what happened it's always switched back
again to oh well he should be more
responsible that was not your initial
argument your initial argument was that
I'm a Nazi he wore Nazi cross he's a
Nazi oh well he's really responsible
he gave a shout-out to Nazi channel he's
a Nazi oh he didn't oh well he should be
more
possible I don't have a PR team and even
if I did I probably get things wrong
anyway I'm always at the end between
these people either the smartest person
ever or the dumbest person ever I'm a
saint around the devil I'm neither of
these things I'm just a normal guy
that's it I don't think about what I
wear that much yes maybe I should but
I'm in a very unique position there's no
one ahead of me I don't know what I'm
doing
help me but what I do realize is that
I'm not apologizing to these lunatics
anymore whatever side you're on you're I
don't like you
I made edgy jokes like what is it
getting on three years now I haven't
done it anymore but I keep getting roped
in based on conspiracy level theories
and yeah I'm not apologizing for that
anymore this is so stupid
next news I feel like I need to make an
update with the whole Pro Jared thing as
well it happened during my honeymoon
and pro jared uploaded finally a
response video saying you've all been
lied to for listen you don't know the
full story I covered this on my channel
so I feel responsible to give an update
at the very least Pro Jared was first
alleged to have cheated on his wife and
people started posting client emojis and
then he came out that he by two people
that he had solicited nudes to minors a
lot of these nudes came out as well and
they became a whole thing you know he
was really killed and he lost over
100,000 subscribers it was pretty
interesting how closely had happened to
the whole James Charles things as well
now poor Jared addressed these two
claims about soliciting newts the first
person had no actual evidence of
interacting with Pro Jared and proteus
response was basically so all we have to
go on is his word and in an instance
such as this where he has no evidence my
word is just as valid as his and here's
the thing with that I don't remember
ever talking to this person none of what
he claimed sounds familiar to my memory
at all okay you know it's not evidence
but if the one making the allegations
doesn't have anything at all
not even a single bit of comfort a
conversation then yeah it's not really
worth much either and what we had heard
in previously from reports was that one
of the people making the claim said
quote he knew I was 16
now Pro Jarret had actual evidence
showing that that wasn't true and the
very first thing that they spoke about
was that he lied about his age our
messages you would have seen where
Charley lied so he did say he was 18 at
least it's a very long video you should
watch it if you're interested and and
you followed this thing and then finally
about the claims about him cheating on
his wife here's what he said and quite
frankly none of that should matter
breakups happen sometimes relationships
don't work out and anything to do with
that is none of your business I agree
you know when when this video came out a
lot of people were really angry at me
they're like you need to update what
happened I'm like wait what I thought I
took a pretty neutral stance on the
whole thing so I went back to check what
I said you know I covered this on my
meme review and this is what I said
mentioning we haven't fully heard Jared
side of the story and a lot of things
are bothering me about this whole thing
there's a lot of puzzle pieces that
don't really make sense to me I don't
think both parties are are completely
blameless here but thanks for papi
Gloria to this side in her video that's
probably coming up tomorrow and in Pew
News this is what I said now Jared
confirms what I already had suspicions
about which was that they were in a
polar polyamorous marriage an open
marriage a mostly marriage I don't know
how it works
and she's the one that asked Jared to be
in this type of relationship and she
suggests that he should engage with
other women as she has done with other
men a lot of people aren't accepting
this as an apology people are saying
well you still solicited nudes to
underage fans and again we don't know if
that's true or not that's all I'm gonna
sing okay you get the point
there was allegations but there was yet
to be no evidence the internet lost
their mind over this program
thing I mean I remember even me just
saying this people got really angry at
me I mean like how dare you defend this
horrible person he is the worst and now
that he cleaned up those claims
everyone's like oh how could you speak
against Ava it's like Jesus Christ dude
the Internet gets so worked up over
these things
not everyone but most I think majority
of people don't think for themselves
they just go with the popular trend or
whatever everyone else is thinking be
like oh this person is bad and this
person is bad all we need to do
something about this and then oh
actually oh they didn't do anything bad
at all oh okay it maybe happen like
right after the whole James Charles
thing where everyone was so sure that
James Charles was the worst and then
that whole thing got flip-flopped as
well and it's like and there's been many
instances of that that I haven't even
even reported as well it's like all
these ideas are like diseases that are
just spread and I don't like it and it's
part of the reason why I didn't I
stopped doing peonies because I hate
playing it into all this drama that it
doesn't mean anything like there's been
so many things happening while I haven't
been doing pew news and I can't even
recite one of them because it doesn't
matter everyone forgets about it a week
after like no one should actually spend
their time caring about these things
it's a waste of time I don't want to
spend my life caring about these things
trust me I'm doing you a favor by not
doing peonies you don't need to know
about these things they're not important
I don't know if Pew news is closed
indefinitely I am going to return to my
retirement but I'll probably be dragged
back the next loop see that PT PI makes
thanks for checking out the merch to
support my retirement and se you gamers
never poppy Gloria out
[Music]
well you haven't tried to Bruce emulator
citizen II after 50 million outros my
ash down just down it's still relevant
just down a bit